[Musique]
quelle est la dernière chose dont tu te
souviens
dany il nous a dit fuir si tu as survécu
c'est parce que tu n'es pas une jeune
fille ordinaire
[Musique]
tu n'es plus seul plus maintenant savez
vous ce qu'est un mutant l'un d'eux vous
souhaite raconter sa première fois rain
j'avais 13 ans c'était comme dans un
rêve
je maîtrisais plus rien
sam j'en sais rien j'ai paniqué il ya eu
des blessés
roberto c'est ma copine je les brûlés
vifs
il y en a j'ai tué 18 personnes une par
pays
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans un hôpital on est en
cash
[Musique]
il est capital d'identifier ton pouvoir
si on veut aider à guérir
j'ai des quelque chose
un truc qu'elle voulait pas que je vois
[Musique]
je crois pas qu'on soit là pour acquérir
cet endroit fait resurgir tu es plus
grande peur ils te les faire vivre
jusqu'à ce qu'elle te tue qui est là
on peut s en sortir ensemble
[Musique]
est ce qui se passe bien chez maman oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe
sa maman tout va bien c'est papa s'est
pas passé comme ça
salez
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas pourquoi vous êtes venus
jusqu'ici ne reste plus rien
oui
les faits
on ne savait rien
moi je sais
les gens qui restent ne valent pas la
peine d'être sauvé
[Musique]
j'écoute
je suis rentré chez moi john jude trouvé
c'est marrant d'avoir peur des fois
c'est grave c'est qu'une peluche que
c'est une telle violence
je comprends que le comportement des jo
de fils vous inquiétez je vous conseille
de lui trouver un endroit où ils se
sentent en sécurité de toute urgence
je pense que ça lui ferait du bien et à
nous aussi
oh la vache regardez moi ce truc ça doit
être le bâtiment principal
tu viens à jude
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on dirait que cette poupée a été cassé
et qu'on a recollé les morceaux qui est
ce charmant garçon brahms dont tu seras
nom pareil il me l'a dit me racontent
plein de choses ça va je trouve tout
c'est un petit peu flippant c'est lui
brahms ton nouvel ami vous parlez de
quoi tous les deux des autres familles
avec qui il a vécu tu veux lui enlever
sa poupée oui au début on entend un
murmure
quelque chose lui arrive il savait que
votre fils le trouverez
[Musique]
je t'aime maman je t'aime aussi
[Applaudissements]
à
je suis
hardy commencé par me dire comment vous
appelez et au milan nom de code le livre
les homes il en existe pas si la
couverture était un bambi toi quoi je
crois vraiment que c'est un espion
justement je suis pas trop gamine est de
fleuriste aucune soit il va se faire
enlever soit la serbie avait fuit pas
mon amour pendant le mec se propres
telles bombes
vous aviez raison louise a été enlevé
l'étape est en fait là que ça fait c'est
parce que vous croyez je vous injecter
des amphétamines pour stimuler locaux du
minho sur elle en concentré jour et
bolbec ce que tu m'a injecté dans le
derche âgées accueillies dans un texto
et à prendre 2 3 move pour te défendre
ce coup le coup d'oeil on les voit une
pousse tous les voyous et les voitures
placebo au comment tu t'es fracassé
vous n'êtes pas un espion à deux numéros
unes jamais se fier aux apparences
arrêté à la fin rag le numéro 2 ferme ta
bouche tu auras show autant vous vous
êtes sûr de vous lui déjà fait en un an
l'ado chine c'était des années 60 on
n'était même pas né qu'est ce que t'en
sais pas ce qui me tue crap
16h06 l'asie pourquoi donc tant qu'homme
se trouva pas
ap
home vous êtes cernés on est deux on est
pareil
[Musique]
et regardez moi ça on y est bien venu 1
kg house
votre père n'a jamais voulu me raconter
sa vie
[Musique]
les enfants ont besoin d'un toit et il
faut que ce soit ce taux là
[Musique]
vous
oui oui
qui a hausse est rempli de clichés
extraordinaire
il faut que tu les écoutes
ils sujet t'as entendu
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gaudy
[Musique]
j'y crois
mais comment c'est possible
[Musique]
c'est pas un jeu on sait par quoi
servent ces clés
on avait réveillé
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui vous
attend
on dit à une créature qui veut c'est clé
une créature maléfique
[Musique]
ces clés sont pas des joueurs
ce sont des armes
ces clés
c'est notre héritage
c'est quelque chose qui nous lie à papa
le passé ne nous quitte jamais
tu as pour essayer qu échapper
il est là et il est toujours là peu
importe ce que tu crois samoura pas pour
déplaire
dutronc
rien foutu cette année ça sert à rien je
passe le bac il suffit juste que tu
mettes et tu l'auras pour t'accompagner
pas toujours drôle je vous déteste c'est
le blanc m'attaque objectifs
stratégiques admis la veille du bateau
rate ou réviser la loi car je suis ravi
de rencontrer votre papa pas sa sueur
un petit rosé bon début si vous pouviez
héritiers de m'appeler mon dd ça va pas
si simple que ça cette cohabitation
allait bien mais c'est marrant quand on
vous voit ensemble tous les deux vous
faites un couple parfait
d'un côté yolande et de l'autre le
bonnet de croix vers un bac pro missiles
en cause de la faim la misère il a dicté
terme gros fainéant mais je voulais
faire ça fait la gendarmette vous à les
mélanger les couleurs et maintenant tout
mais souhaite m'en sors tu peux vous
prêtez mesli pas si vous voulez qu'ils
frère à celui-là avec les yeux qui
pensent ça c'était avant
ça se passe bien entre vous impeccable
tout à fait quoi s'affoler pas touche
comment cactus a tu veux la guerre mon
petit frère
ces pauvres dames
[Musique]
tiens tu vas voir j'adore ton permis
dès 14 h
[Musique]
vous êtes donc les deux grands pères de
camille je vais vous expliquer mais tu
sais donner la parole dont madame alors
vous l'avez la main bonjour je m'appelle
adrien j'ai 27 ans je suis acteur
d'ailleurs je vous avez peut-être vu
j'ai fait pas mal de films quand j'étais
petit et de boucherie chez un patient 45
minutes par tenant a été saisie monsieur
palatine ne vous appartient plus je suis
le second on n'avale pas la carte des
gens je souhaite une décision de justice
maintenant je bosse je serai une carte
printemps bien sûr tout à nantua
[Musique]
vous foutez de ma gueule non
par exemple la fois j'étais avec une
fille on s'embrassait hélas rien pas un
soupçon de rigueur rien en slip quoi
pour aller montrer moins l'asticot à ok
mais quoi alors je rigole je suis pas un
truc de toi ça et penser consulter pour
non ça c'est pas de ma mère est pire
raconte la vieille mère vient pour la
fête en fête
adrien mon fils j'ai des punaises de lit
chez lui donc il est revenu habiter chez
sa maman
[Musique]
taux
tu prends la drogue bon enfin je suis un
peu de crack à stalingrad le samedi soir
mais a prêché va aussi acheter blake
merci beaucoup lui la non désolé je n'ai
fait que révéler ce qu'ils étaient des
gens toi je tourne vers les yeux
d'abord j'aimerais qu'on souhaite la
bienvenue à deux nouveaux élèves
magna et le rite son frère je vous
laisse vous présenter à vos camarades
j'ai un peu d'avancé j'ai sauté des
classes magna lui les il est doué pour
plein d'autres choses
c'est comme si tout avait changé depuis
mon arrivée a aidé à ce que je suis
devenu invincible
on peut dire que c'est ici que s'est
produit le dernier combat entre les
dieux et les géants
qu'est ce que vous savez sur eux ce
jeune homme qui vient d'arriver dans ta
classe je te garde un oeil sur lui lui
c'est fiore c'est un youtube le
troisième du nom toutes les filles sont
dingues de lui
le dissident qui parmi eux vit humeur
pour ça faudrait déjà qu'on soit en
guerre les géants sont toujours parmi
nous les humains les regarde détruire le
monde sans rien faire aucun humain aime
la force d'affronter semences jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
une sorte de virus ici
elle avait vu quelque chose là haut
nous n'avons pas eu d'ennemis comme lui
depuis au moins mille ans
[Applaudissements]
les l'on mange les animaux sauf si
quelqu'un baissions tueur est temps de
le saouler style et je te garantis
dis moi qui tu rêves et vous qui êtes
vous
la quête de notre héros est sur le point
de débuter
à jean bellorini allen c'est pas facile
d'être parents
sauf dans notre cas évidemment vous êtes
obligé de faire ça je peux pas vous
laisser partir sympa vos discussions le
rôle principal de presidio n'est pas de
tuer les monstres c'est de les
comprendre comment vont vivre et jazz
est-ce qu'ils s'adaptent but vide et moi
on se fait arracher à nos vies et
traînés de force dans ce plein les
jumeaux de 17 ans j'ai jamais rien
affronter aussi terrifiant que ça wahou
vous êtes les parents de l'année vous
écoute on va essayer de parler en séance
les séances me font flipper il faut
graver en ferry génial
tu as vu un truc pas net je me trouve
qu'est ce qui s'est passé cellule locale
a été liquidée ça doit être terrifiante
et vivre dans la peur en ce jour là quel
point on est gêné râble
quoi ça jd ciné ça avant l'instant
est-ce que ça va
et ça vous plaise ou non
des espèces dans ce monde doivent être
mes parents sont occupés à sauver le
monde joël mois d'octobre